here now is harmee dillon chairwoman of
the republican national lawyers
association
harmeet you say this is a start
but this needs to be one of many such
motions to keep up this momentum explain
for us
well thank you laura so two weeks ago
there was this unprecedented raid on the
president's home the former president's
home and one of the things that they
asked for today is the appointment of a
special master so to unpack that
normally what happens after a uh
execution of a search warrant like this
is that the department of justice
assigns a separate team of prosecutors
to look over those materials to suss out
anything that's privileged or otherwise
should not be seen by the main
prosecutor so in the time that it's
taken you know to get to this point it
may already be the case that the doj has
already gone through that process and
handed off a bunch of documents to the
prosecutors on the case now if you trust
them uh that is the doj prosecutors
assigned on either side of that to do
the right thing then no problem but if
you don't trust them then this sort of
appointment of a special master that is
an independent lawyer or former judge or
what have you to oversee that process
independently
uh that should already have been done so
you know i hope it isn't too late for
that particular motion but some other
things that need to need to be
considered are is this judge judge bruce
reinhardt who's clearly shown himself to
be biased is he the correct person to be
ruling on these issues should there be a
motion to recuse that judge it's always
risky to file such a motion
there is mention in this filing today of
return of property i don't think it was
really fleshed out so hopefully i think
maybe the trump team is waiting for
the rulings on thursday after judge
reinhardt looks at the redaction
requests and some other issues to see
to see about that and get more direction
on that but i think this is just the
first step there needs to be a very
aggressive response to this because this
is not just about president trump
there's about the fourth amendment this
is about the executive branch of
government this is about whether the
espionage act even should apply at all
to a former president under these
circumstances so for all of these
reasons is deeply troubling and i'm glad
to see them taking this first step there
need to be a lot more harmy like like
clockwork we knew this was going to
happen the new york times tonight got a
leak from the feds saying that trump had
more than 300 classified documents
at mar-a-lago among the items they knew
were missing were mr trump's original
letters from the north korean dictator
kim jong-un
and the note that president barack obama
had left
trump before he left office harmeed it
goes on and on
and they always source people
with familiarity of the case but it
whether it's the national archives folks
or them in in conversations with doj
somebody gave that information to maggie
haberman who is you know she's she's a
good reporter she's
she takes the stuff and runs with it
but this is what happened in russiagate
is it not it's drip drip drip
laura the very fact that this is how the
united states department of justice
plays its games
should be front and center in a motion
about about a special master that type
of shenanigan is exactly what god a
special master appointed in the project
veritas case where the fbi rated
american journalists on a very flimsy
pretext because of ashley biden's diary
and so here similarly i think that is
actually something that can be used on
the offense it is improper for the doj
it is a violation of the doj's
regulations as a violation of law to use
the press in this manner and and frankly
even after you
set aside all the hype in that article
and take it at face value
uh so what i mean we learned during the
hillary clinton email scandal that
overclassification is a rampant hillary
clinton wasn't even the former president
and you know it it it still is not an
excuse 18 months after this person has
left office to raid his home and one of
the good things that this motion does
today is tell the story of how president
trump's team was cooperating all along
it was his own house he put an extra
lock and the next thing you know there
are 30 fbi agents there so that's great
let me just jump in
but now the the scuttlebutt is about
when are we going to get the
internal surveillance video of the
storage room and then there's another
storage room
but this so reminds me of what happened
during the mueller investigation
to keep the narrative going politically
they have to do this
it's the same playbook we've seen it
from day one and there is a network
there is a there is a corrupt symbiotic
relationship between the mainstream
media and the uh and the solons who
control the department of justice uh and
so
this should not be the case for any
american this is how they play it at
every level and it needs to stop and if
merrick garland had any integrity he
would be coming out and holding a press
conference right now talking about the
outrageous behavior of the department of
justice and the investigation that he is
going to ask to be held into these leaks
and and and the violations of doj policy
you don't see him doing that because
this is a feature and not a bug
of the system oh i love that line
harmony we're going to find out who
leaked that information to maggie
haberman like we're going to find out
who
leaked the draft opinion in the dobbs
case i'm not i'm not holding my breath
on either of those but harmy you've
given some great insight tonight we
really appreciate it thank you